Gaurav Subedi: Hey, Ted.
Chad Nicely: I don't tell them I have any pain clients.
Chad Nicely: No. Let's meet with, just tell him you might have one. Let's meet with Coffey and,
Chad Nicely: Mark, I just want to make sure we get this done so we can do this demo tomorrow, right?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, okay.
Chad Nicely: It shouldn't be hard to open those implants, right?
Gaurav Subedi: The electromagn one?
Chad Nicely: No, GC.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay.
M. A. Kafi: Hello?
Chad Nicely: Hey, coffee.
Chad Nicely: So you recall?
M. A. Kafi: Yes.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Well, I'm mainly trying to talk to Ahmad, but I thought you might just be able to help me, right?
M. A. Kafi: In a nutshell?
Chad Nicely: So, does somebody want to share their screen so we can look at the broadcast settings and what needs to be public?
M. A. Kafi: Yeah, I can.
Gaurav Subedi: coffee you can do there.
Chad Nicely: I'm gonna make you host, then.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
M. A. Kafi: Mmm, Korop, you need to set the permission.
M. A. Kafi: Hmm, can you see my screen?
Chad Nicely: Yes
Chad Nicely: Coffee's adding a new one on the top left, a mod, that's gonna be called Clickers, and it's where…
Chad Nicely: You can just mail the clickers, right?
Ammad Sarfraz: Right, I checked it.
Chad Nicely: So, there's gonna be one for openers, and then you have all the activity for it, and then there's gonna be one for clickers, and you have all the activity for it.
Chad Nicely: Right?
Ammad Sarfraz: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Now, scroll down…
Chad Nicely: I don't think he has that done yet, but scroll down…
Chad Nicely: And see where it says, add extra conditions?
M. A. Kafi: Yes.
Chad Nicely: Okay, so that's the extra stuff that you haven't done yet, Ahmad, see?
Chad Nicely: Support.
Ammad Sarfraz: Oh, yes.
Chad Nicely: So you have inactive… You see?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yep.
Chad Nicely: And then you have activity level for it.
Ammad Sarfraz: Okay.
Chad Nicely: And then you have passive, and then you have new, and then you have dead, and all those have activity levels.
Ammad Sarfraz: Right.
Chad Nicely: So, just so you guys understand, tomorrow, I need to say, okay, write the email, which it does.
Chad Nicely: Place an image, which it does. Place a link, which it does.
Chad Nicely: Then it's gonna say, do you want to…
Chad Nicely: Send to an activity, or do you want to send to tags? I'm going to say, send to activity.
Chad Nicely: It's gonna say, do you want to send it clickers or openers? I'm gonna say clickers.
Chad Nicely: And by default, it's gonna show me all activity for the clickers. It's gonna say there's 2,000 available.
Chad Nicely: And then it's gonna say, do you want to add,
Chad Nicely: Extra conditions, I'm gonna say yes.
Chad Nicely: And then what's gonna happen, G, is we need to recommend, okay, I recommend about 15% of the $2,000, right?
Chad Nicely: Makes sense.
Chad Nicely: If it knows there's 2,000 active clickers, it's gonna recommend about 10-15% of those, right, G?
Chad Nicely: Hello?
M. A. Kafi: Mmm, Iji, you are muted.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah?
Chad Nicely: I said.
Gaurav Subedi: No, I was assisting other, so…
Chad Nicely: I said, if it's gonna mail 2,000 active clickers, then it knows It's gonna re-engage about 10-15%.
Gaurav Subedi: Automatically.
Chad Nicely: Well, it's gonna recommend it.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, yeah.
Chad Nicely: So you say, yeah, let's do 15%, and then it's gonna know.
Chad Nicely: Okay, well, I pulled my inactives first?
Chad Nicely: I pulled my new ones next.
Chad Nicely: I pull my passive next, and then dead.
Chad Nicely: So what you should do, Coffey, is you should change the order on the right. You should have inactive, new, passive, and dead.
Chad Nicely: Does that make sense?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah.
M. A. Kafi: Inactive, passive, new, and dead?
Chad Nicely: No, inactive, new, passive, dead.
M. A. Kafi: Okay.
Chad Nicely: That's your priority, right? So it's gonna know, gee, like, we're gonna train it, To say, like, okay, well…
Chad Nicely: If I do 10% in 2,000, that's 200.
Chad Nicely: I'm just gonna say, I found… 20 inactive. I've included those.
Chad Nicely: I found 50 in passive.
Chad Nicely: I included those. Nothing was in new.
Ammad Sarfraz: and dead…
Chad Nicely: I pulled the rest out of dead.
Chad Nicely: And then it's gonna give a summary down below of, okay, we're sending to 2,000 active clickers.
Chad Nicely: We're sent into… Whatever I said, 20 inactive, 10 passive… And… 150 dead. Make sense?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: And then you're gonna click send.
Chad Nicely: You're gonna tell it to send. Those are the endpoints I need, Ahmad.
Ammad Sarfraz: I'm working on the workflow create with emails.
Chad Nicely: Yeah.
Ammad Sarfraz: Yeah, well, and I…
Chad Nicely: That one's gonna be pretty easy, or no?
Ammad Sarfraz: No, because we are doing the bulk editor from the front end.
Ammad Sarfraz: From the UI, then it sends the data back-end, so I have to create a backend API to handle it.
Ammad Sarfraz: From the… From the backend itself.
Chad Nicely: Maybe you should do this first, then, because this is what I need to demo tomorrow.
Ammad Sarfraz: Okay, okay, I will do this first.
Chad Nicely: This one should be easier, right?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yep.
Chad Nicely: So, here's my other thing, guys. If I don't choose… if it writes the email, and I choose by tags, it's gonna say how many tags you want to send. I'm gonna say 2.
Chad Nicely: Is he gonna be able to pull both those tags, Coffee?
Chad Nicely: Or G, or whoever can answer.
M. A. Kafi: Sorry, I missed that, I was checking this one.
Chad Nicely: Asking, gee, if I say I want to mail to the tags, Right, so click on Tag.
Chad Nicely: Right, so I can choose a tag, right? I can choose open… interested open claw.
M. A. Kafi: I guess I'm on the wrong account.
Gaurav Subedi: It's fine, select your…
M. A. Kafi: Select anything, anyone?
Chad Nicely: Yeah, so you select anything.
Chad Nicely: And then… It should be able to choose another tag up above.
Chad Nicely: Do you see?
Chad Nicely: So now, if we can do it to where you can select multiple tags right now, and the activity for the tag, right? Do you choose the activity? No, you don't choose activity, do you?
Gaurav Subedi: On the same place? Are you talking about, like, instead of separate tabs?
Chad Nicely: I'm saying, if you're not doing activity, you're doing tags, right?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah?
Chad Nicely: So click on tag again, G, we're done… we're done with activity, right? So choose your tag.
Chad Nicely: Right, and you need to choose activity. Okay.
Chad Nicely: So…
Chad Nicely: there's two things that we don't have, and we can do it later. Right now, I would just like to be able to say, mail the two tags, right?
Chad Nicely: Does that make sense?
Gaurav Subedi: And when you say two tags, we have selected two tags on the top. One is 11 Santiago.
Chad Nicely: Yes. Yeah.
Gaurav Subedi: I agree, yeah.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, but now you can add extra conditions to each one of those tags.
Chad Nicely: That part I don't think we have built yet, you see?
Gaurav Subedi: Okay, so when you said multiple tags, this is the right way, right? Like, right now, we can select… we're selecting two tags, and we can send an email to those two tags.
Chad Nicely: Correct.
Gaurav Subedi: When you said extra condition, we can still do it.
Chad Nicely: It's extra condition for each tag.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: The endpoint's gonna be different than the extra conditions for activity, right?
Chad Nicely: Okay, so what I'm saying is, we don't have to get into the extra conditions for the tags yet.
Chad Nicely: Also… what you might do is click on Activity.
Chad Nicely: You also have an exclusion, see it?
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: So that's where, Ahmad, you say, okay, I want to mail all active clickers
Chad Nicely: But I don't want it to be anybody that's in this tag, this tag, or this tag. Make sense?
Ammad Sarfraz: Yes.
Chad Nicely: Any questions?
Ammad Sarfraz: Nope.
Chad Nicely: So that's the demo I have to do tomorrow, Iman.
Chad Nicely: On the workshop.
Ammad Sarfraz: Okay, let me work on it.
Chad Nicely: Alright, any questions?
Ammad Sarfraz: Not yet.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, get that done, then let's test it, and then we can work on building out the workflow.
Ammad Sarfraz: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Alright, thank you.
Ammad Sarfraz: Thank you.
Ammad Sarfraz: Right.
Chad Nicely: Gee, why don't we check in with Adarshia?
Gaurav Subedi: Yes, sir.
Chad Nicely: Why? They got rid of a mom.
Chad Nicely: You want, the options like this?
Chad Nicely: Yeah, that's good.
M. A. Kafi: I reported it with both.
Chad Nicely: I wouldn't do default both.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, actually, you don't need… you don't need both, right? Because…
Chad Nicely: Openers includes clickers, you don't need both, you just need openers or clickers, right?
Chad Nicely: By default, both is… both is openers, right?
M. A. Kafi: Yes.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, so you don't need both, that was my stupid decision.
Chad Nicely: That was the wrong decision.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
Gaurav Subedi: So, is this…
M. A. Kafi: Open and click.
Chad Nicely: You definitely need it on the left-hand side, though, coffee.
M. A. Kafi: Yeah, I tried on the lip, but…
Chad Nicely: Oh, okay. Well, Adarsha can do it for you, that's fine.
M. A. Kafi: No, I can do that as well, but that was not showing good.
M. A. Kafi: Like this?
Chad Nicely: But you got a space…
M. A. Kafi: Yeah, we can do the space.
Chad Nicely: Are you sure you can add a space?
Adarsha Shrestha: You can just add…
M. A. Kafi: MBS.
Adarsha Shrestha: Yes, I'm thinking… MBMB.
Chad Nicely: But you have Adarsha here to make it all pretty, coffee, you don't have to do it yourself.
Gaurav Subedi: you add it both ways, if you just do MB.
M. A. Kafi: Bottom only? Okay.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: Coffee understands design like I do.
Chad Nicely: Right?
M. A. Kafi: Yes.
Chad Nicely: I think we could have a race to see who could fix this faster. Who do you think would win?
M. A. Kafi: these things?
Chad Nicely: Yeah.
M. A. Kafi: I guess Adarshocaine?
Chad Nicely: No, no, no. I said if you and I were to race to see who could…
M. A. Kafi: Oh.
Chad Nicely: faster. Who do you think would fix it faster?
M. A. Kafi: Through the HTML, I guess I can do.
Chad Nicely: I'm pretty sure I would win.
M. A. Kafi: No, I was trying to do both ways.
Chad Nicely: I get it. Alright, so… Darsha, how are we looking on Quizforma?
Adarsha Shrestha: I have added a template, but it is not
Adarsha Shrestha: blowing on the data, I don't know why. I'm looking why it's not showing.
Chad Nicely: Did you ask Claude Code why it didn't show?
Adarsha Shrestha: It's not working… it's not showing on the postman as well. It's not coming from the backend.
Chad Nicely: Gee, do we have cloud code just connected to the repository, or no?
Gaurav Subedi: No?
Chad Nicely: Are we not comfortable doing that?
Gaurav Subedi: Not with Quiz Pharma yet.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Because that's.
Gaurav Subedi: I think it's the… it's the backend problem.
Chad Nicely: That's what Karthik's gonna advise you to do, is connect everything to repositories.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, we'll be doing that shortly.
Chad Nicely: What, what does the template look like?
Adarsha Shrestha: I guess.
Gaurav Subedi: He never got to create it, like, he created the… oh, you can show it?
Adarsha Shrestha: I can show the preview.
Gaurav Subedi: Problem is… It just doesn't add, right?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, it's not showing on the Quiz Pharma app.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, but once you get it, you can do multiple templates, right?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, I have created multiple templates, I can send them.
Chad Nicely: Yes, sure.
Adarsha Shrestha: What?
Chad Nicely: Just share your screen and show them to me, I just want to see if they have the right look.
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, okay.
Chad Nicely: Can you see under her arm?
Adarsha Shrestha: Tensit?
Chad Nicely: No, I see… echo.
Adarsha Shrestha: It's just a preview. Can you see the preview?
Chad Nicely: No.
Gaurav Subedi: You're setting the wrong screen.
Adarsha Shrestha: 30.
Adarsha Shrestha: Okay, can you see it now?
Chad Nicely: Pretty bad, right? Deep.
Chad Nicely: You guys should take the egg out altogether.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, so it made that?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, this is one, one of, one of the… Templet.
Adarsha Shrestha: This is the another one.
Adarsha Shrestha: I have created multiple templates.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, I like the… this one's better.
Chad Nicely: But, like, the text should be going all the way across, right?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: So, yeah, see, that's good.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, that's good. So, when you… oh man, look at that, G.
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, I have created multiple teams.
Chad Nicely: So it's pretty easy to do this.
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: Wow… So, if you say to it,
Chad Nicely: What does it look like on mobile?
Adarsha Shrestha: Mmm… It looks good on mobile, too.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, I don't like the first one, but…
Chad Nicely: If you say to it, refer to… SurveyMonkey, Typeform…
Chad Nicely: Like, if I just give you quizzes that I've saved over time.
Chad Nicely: Can it look at that and, like, create that too?
Adarsha Shrestha: I can try, I can try giving the preview.
Adarsha Shrestha: See if we can create it.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, it's a prompt that you ran to create this.
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah.
Adarsha Shrestha: I gave, I gave the data, the input flows that it needs.
Adarsha Shrestha: And I asked to create it.
Chad Nicely: So now, if you ask it to create, like, Typeform, what does it do?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, I need to take a glue.
Adarsha Shrestha: Daipum…
Chad Nicely: Typeform T-Y-P-E-F-O-R-M.
Chad Nicely: So, will it automatically code at all, too, where we can't screw it up, like…
Chad Nicely: You know how, like, when we were trying to do these templates, it was screwed up, some of the fields pulled in, some of them didn't, like…
Chad Nicely: Will it do it correctly?
Adarsha Shrestha: I'm not 100% sure if it will do correctly.
Adarsha Shrestha: But if we provided the right input first, then you should do it correctly?
Chad Nicely: If you were to ask Claude Code, if you were to say.
Chad Nicely: what's the best that, Typeform has to offer visually?
Chad Nicely: Can you pull those things in? What would it say?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, I need to… Give it the prompt and check.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, I mean, our back-end functionality is good enough, now I'm just trying to make the front ends look incredible, right?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: And what'd you say it looked like on the phone?
Adarsha Shrestha: It looks good on the mobile as well.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, I'm anxious to see what this looks like.
Chad Nicely: So, what can we do to help? Anything?
Adarsha Shrestha: Hmm, not right now.
Adarsha Shrestha: And…
Adarsha Shrestha: I will add some more templates, and I'll provide in the JIP. You can just copy-paste all the fields here.
Adarsha Shrestha: I'll provide him all this.
Chad Nicely: Provide who?
Adarsha Shrestha: Vivek. You can just copy-paste it.
Adarsha Shrestha: And you can bring it on.
M. A. Kafi: So, you need to do that through API.
Chad Nicely: But you have access, don't you?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, I have added here the template.
Adarsha Shrestha: But it's not, coming on the… From the backend.
Adarsha Shrestha: It's not swing here.
Adarsha Shrestha: It's.
M. A. Kafi: Oh, we just need to ask PBEC to give us the… Documentation.
M. A. Kafi: He can give…
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah, we can do that as well.
Gaurav Subedi: They're already working on the template, the API talk.
Chad Nicely: Do you have the.
Gaurav Subedi: template.
Chad Nicely: Yeah, he finished the API docs today, do you want to look at it?
Gaurav Subedi: No, this is the admin template, admin, yeah.
Gaurav Subedi: Yeah, it won't be there, Jared. This is a separate one.
Chad Nicely: Okay, so when Adarsha does what he does.
Chad Nicely: he's gonna give these… this documentation to Vivek, and then Vivek's gonna connect it all, and then we can create as many templates as we want.
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
M. A. Kafi: You also need to secure the route Because it can't be… Discovered accidentally, and… Anyone can delete the templates.
Chad Nicely: Alright, well, just help me with whatever we give him, K, because I don't understand…
Chad Nicely: But he can do that tonight.
Chad Nicely: Cause he's done with the docks.
Chad Nicely: And then Kashelle's working on the Poplink templates.
Chad Nicely: And then, after that, I might get your help.
Chad Nicely: on the MintBird templates, too.
Chad Nicely: Darsha.
Adarsha Shrestha: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Alright, so this is definitely a lot easier, huh?
Adarsha Shrestha: Yeah.
Chad Nicely: Okay, good.
Chad Nicely: And then, G, I asked Renee to look into… I sent him how to connect OpenCloud to Zoom Messenger.
Chad Nicely: It said there is a way with the OAuth, so I don't know.
Gaurav Subedi: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Do you guys need anything from me?
Gaurav Subedi: Not right now.
Chad Nicely: Okay.
Chad Nicely: Alright, well, I'll be around if you guys need anything, okay?
Adarsha Shrestha: Okay, bye-bye.
Chad Nicely: Alright, buh-bye.
M. A. Kafi: Bye bye.